the movies Sean executive-produced it's
called let there be light
is out in theaters today earlier this
week Sean spoke with Kevin and Sam Sorbo
as well as their son Brayden about the
film
take a look alright so this is the
weekend let there be light theaters near
you on Hannity calm
let there be light movie calm we hope
you go see it yes we are taking over
Hollywood at least we're gonna try Kevin
Sam Sorbo Braden Sorbo you by the end of
this weekend you're gonna be a rock star
you know that I hope you so mean to your
father in the movie he was mean to mean
you what is that what's up with that I
did a good job
Oh see I like it a lot of confidence but
you did do a good job
alright so about it was about a year and
a half nearly two years ago I had God
was it God's not dead cause I did a
great job for guys that Daddy came for
Soul Surfer knowledge yeah you called me
up and said I want to do a movie with
you what was I thinking we do yeah and
we came here with Dan Gordon who
co-wrote with with Sam and we pitched
you and why keep telling people I got we
thought for 20-25 minutes Dan Gore
didn't stop and Shawn didn't interrupt
one time I don't have that reputation
but here's what I've been saying all the
interviews that I've done I have been
saying
Hollywood is formulaic this is what you
get in Hollywood you get sex violence
you get spider-man 90 you get Jennifer
Aniston falls in love with whoever the
new Hollywood person is and then they
break up or they get married or they
fall in love and they have a baby and a
dog and in the movie yes mm-hmm that's
pretty much it sir and there has been
contempt for conservative Christian
faith values in Hollywood yeah and this
is I think an antidote and we went
independent which means is it totally
different you know this is this is the
story of like Sam brought this up before
but going back to what Hollywood used to
be before the 60s and everything changed
you know where do you do movies we have
characters that clowns can identify with
and like and want to see the movies over
and over and over again well tell people
you are the mean
he writes a book aborting God and is
proud of it
I was acting he abandoned his family you
were a drunk a womanizer a drug addict
and you helped transform his life you
had the patients a job dealing with him
well you know you you you write a story
that hopefully is compelling you want
people to be interested in in order to
be compelling you have to have
characters that sort of brush against
extremes and his growth as an arc you
want to see this you have to juxtapose
it with what he was before to what he
becomes and that I think that's what's
appealing to people is they they
identify people identify a little bit
with each of the characters in the movie
and that's what's great about the movie
that's why it touches people so every
single person I've shown this movie to
cries yeah everyone yeah and your son
makes them cry yeah no you don't you
know director or dictator this was my
first movie it was a lot of fun you and
your brother did fantastic and you're
protecting your mom against him is that
what was like in real life he has a
two-parent family I think for a lot of
kids his age in the in a single-parent
family it comes to that right I mean
that's why this this film touches people
because they recognize that there's a
lot of real reality in this movie in the
screenings we've done and get
testimonials from people we're finding
out that women love it but men love it
even more because it touches them too
it's because we do have a father problem
in this country you look what they do in
sitcoms the dads are almost fat and
opions too for the moms not their kids
make fun of dad you got generations
growing up with this over the last 20-30
years how do they treat that we're
treated that way I think this is also
grab them from the front pages you're
right it's it hits every societal
problem but in as much as if there's a
debate on a college campus today and the
guy that writes aborting God and it's
debating a Christian he's going to have
the crowd on his side oh yeah and
and the most amazing thing is you're
torn back to come back you have all your
handlers that want you to make more
money and more money and more money and
you try to work out well he becomes you
know he has he has an event that
definitely changes the worldview that
makes him actually go spiral even
further down because he doesn't know how
to handle this that hasn't come out yet
can anyone explain that in the inter
Film Festival right we entered a Film
Festival and we won an award it was
fantastic